even though this Black Friday when the
dollar flew first broke out the
authorities gathered the second an area
in the middle of Manhattan they brought
in the best scientists and the most
cutting-edge medical equipment to try
and contain the virus and look for a
cure but fairly quickly the government
realized that their attempts to control
the virus were not enough more and more
people were becoming infected and
medical personnel and equipment were
being pushed to their limits Sarah or
the catastrophic emergency response
agency is a federal agency whose primary
focus is to deal with large-scale
natural disasters in the division the
goal is to stop the spread of the virus
they're responsible for supplying aid
through supplies medical facilities and
civilian camps but also for the
quarantine zones Sarah was heavily
involved with the quarantine of
Manhattan the joint task force jtf is a
coalition of the police firefighters
civil volunteers and Army National
Guardsmen they were given the role of
working in tandem with Sarah to assist
with stopping the spread of the virus
and maintaining order however the JTF
and Sarah gradually started to lose grip
on control of the situation as the virus
continue to spread causing panic rioting
looting and the uprising of hostile
groups this is when the first wave of
strategic homeland division agents were
activated their goal to assist the JTF
and regain control of the city
unfortunately it was too late shortly
after the first wave division agents
were released into the dark zone Zahra
and the JTF pulled out leaving behind
supplies medicine weapons thousands of
infected and the first wave agents
abandoned and cut off from the outside
world many agents succumb to the virus
or were killed by the growing hostile
factions within the quarantine zone
understandably the first wave agents
were unhappy with how things had been
handled by Sarah the JTF and the
government and this is where we're
introduced to a prominent figure in this
division storyline Aran kena Aran Kino
was a first wave agent who after the
abandonment of the quarantine zone
became disillusioned with the government
its plan to save the city
[Music]
[Music]
KYNA disavowed the division and went
rogue
his first action after turning against
the government was to recruit other
first wave agents into his new focus of
survival and power any agents that
refused were killed causing other agents
to cut communications and go into hiding
this is the event that triggered the
second wave to be activated their goal
was to investigate what happened and why
the majority of the first wave had gone
missing in action after forming his
group of rogue agents Keenum it up with
the commanding officer of the last man
battalion Charles bliss they agreed to
collaborate through a deal that would
benefit them both kina wanted to use the
LMB
to assistant operations to establish
dominance over Manhattan and Bliss
wanted access to the division shade
technology to gain advantage over other
hostile groups kina with the LMB
launched many operations against
opposing groups including the JTF one of
the most notable being an attack on a
helicopter that was carrying a division
commander that was in charge of the
second wave division agents the only
survivors were fail ow and the player
agent during his time working with the
LMB kina was also investigating the
virus outbreak he found that dr. Gordon
Amherst was responsible and his plans
were to use a weaponized virus as
leverage it was around this time that
the presence of errant kina was
discovered by the division and their who
was working as a rogue agent against the
United States kinas investigation led
him to dr. Vitaly training Co in the
Russian consulate who was also
researching the virus he organized some
of his rogue agents to kidnap turn echo
and his research keener ends up
betraying the LMB by leaving with
treinen co welter JTF in the division
assault the UN compound to shut down the
alien be base and take down bliss the
kina found and her slab as well as some
virus samples a 3d DNA printer and also
Amherst's notes his plan is to use Tran
anko and the samples to weaponize the
virus and to use it to fulfill his
belief that only those that are smart
enough and good enough survive the old
rules laws and governments are gone now
only survival and power matter
the division and the US government are
now fully aware of kinas intentions
he's now wanted for high treason and has
the potential of being registered as a
terrorist it was later discovered that
keener had spent some time in the West
Side Pier at this stage all hostile
groups had feuds with him most of all
the LMB he broadcast at his location to
bring all hostile factions to this area
to hunt him down which in turn brought
the JTF
and division agents whose distraction
helped keep the hostile groups from
finding him during this time he also
taunted the division agents stating that
no one will ever find him and despite
the quarantines and lockdowns of the
island he'll soon be gone it's now
confirmed that Aaron Keena is long gone
from Manhattan and likely New York City
altogether his location is currently
unknown but he continues to leave
messages for JTF and other government
agents to convince them of his ways and
beliefs and to join him and his agents
and working against the government his
final message was to inform us that his
eyes are set not just on the United
States but now the world there's a whole
world out there for me to take a bite
out of well maybe you can figure out
just how I did it maybe you'll decide to
do the same one day when you get tired
of fighting an endless fight for people
who just aren't worth it when that time
comes maybe you and I can work together
after all just one last thing if you
ever get off this rock don't come
looking for me when I need to I'll find
you
hey guys thanks for watching I'm a huge
fan of game law and follow a number of
law channels for games that have long
since stopped playing this is my first
attempt into this type of video and
truth be told I could have prattled on
for another 30 minutes or so on the
subject based on the information I found
but I wanted to keep it short and sweet
for this first one this game has a
number of unanswered questions or groups
and individuals that could use further
explanation I quite enjoyed the research
into this and look forward to digging
deeper into the story if you'd like to
see more of this type of content just
let me know what you think Cheers
[Music]